-Hey, I'm Finn Wolfhard
and this is "Three Scoops."
Okay. So there's a lot of
"Stranger Things" fan theories.
Um, there's been a lot over the
years since the show came out.
One weird one that I saw was,
like,
it was like a "Wizard of Oz"
parallel
it was like the Mind Flayer
is Dorothy.
I don't know how people got
there, but respect it.
My all-time favorite movie,
actually no, is "The Graduate."
It's amazing.
It's a perfect movie.
I feel like this'll be
problematic.
And I feel like I'll ruin my job
by saying these things.
I hate fruit.
I hate all fruit.
I know that's, like,
gonna seem like a, like,
a cringy, like, quirky thing,
but I've always hated it.
And I'm just, you know -- that's
just me being honest, baby.
It's Finn Wolfhard
and that was "Three Scoops."